good morning John and happy beats miss
as I think you expected people have been
enjoying your green screen time Makana
John Green screamed
it's a thing it's beautiful and I want
to skip back another video to the almost
incalculably distant Friday video that I
did in which I use the word diphthong
which unfortunately does not exist what
I was going for was diphthong which is
also really great
I have pronounced and spelled diphthong
wrong for at least a decade I am NOT
embarrassed about my misunderstanding
with the diphthong word and I want to
know why in college I did an oral
presentation on Leon Battista Alberti
who is a mathematician and architect and
artist of the Renaissance super cool
dude if you ever want to learn about he
designed a great number of the Front's
of buildings in Florence those fronts of
buildings are called that word which I
said for the entire presentation the
Cade like 26 times I said fake aid and I
knew something wasn't going well but I
just powered through you know and then
found out later I'm a friend
facade
so I mispronounced diphthong in front of
200,000 people didn't bother me Akane in
front of 20 people we lay like left a
permanent scar like I still have a hard
time telling that story what is the
difference between those two things I
think it's mostly confidence like being
confident when you're wrong is one of
the most amazing things you can be it's
wonderful if you can pull it off which
is impossible I don't mean confidence in
believing a thing that is wrong and
continuing to believe a thing despite
knowing that it's wrong which some
people are really into I mean finding
out you're wrong knowing you're wrong
and being confident in your
understanding of your own wrongness you
see somebody be super wrong and be like
whatever I was wrong damn thanks for
letting me know you're like that person
is cool
they're cool how do I get that feeling
fine about being wrong is the logical
way to feel because as I have pointed
out in previous videos I am a towering
mountain of ignorance and all simplicity
is a lie even when you're right you're a
little bit wrong getting to a place
where I feel comfortable enough with
myself to have internalized that truth
even a little bit has been a lifelong
process and it really it only works when
I'm in places and with people who I
trust and know and understand and feel
good about and feel confident around
which is the case here the vlog with his
channel in nerdfighteria embarrassment
really isn't about being wrong it's
about feeling wrong and it is hard for
me to feel wrong here because you guys
are nice sometimes the most embarrassing
part of the embarrassment is the
embarrassment itself that's weird in the
comments of my Friday video I owned up
and I said that I mispronounced it all
just like John recently missed
pronunciation and I asked people tell me
about their hectacre moments and I read
through them just before I made this
video and it was wonderful there's like
300 replies and they are all hilarious
and wince-inducing look several of them
were also facade which made me feel
better about myself and I think in
general that thread was cathartic for
all the people who participated it being
wrong is part of what it is to be a
person you have to work on how to be
wrong without feeling wrong I think that
thread was a good start so I'm going to
ask all of you
a little time tell us an embarrassing
thing that has happened to you we can
read about it and feel better about
ourselves knowing that everyone does
dumb things but I think owning it is the
number one thing you can do and I think
the other thing you can do is let people
know who are admitting to their
embarrassing things that have happened
to them that they're awesome and that
that's hilarious and not to worry about
it that's hopefully what's going on in
the comments John I'll see you tomorrow
high end screen this is sad only three
days left of pizza miss but the project
for awesome is coming up so there are
reasons to celebrate the future because
of Paper Towns shoot dates were actually
moving the project for awesome up this
year it's going to be the 12th and the
13th of December so mark your calendars
start planning your videos